hey guys i'm ryan right hey guys so
we're here today to watch the trailer
for the fourth installment of DreamWorks
shrek oh we're really excited how
pleasant well the new title is shrek is
love shrek is life part 4 [__] [__]
who made this there's nothing wrong with
it it's just about a guy who gets raped
and now he has a you know and a
traumatic experience where he is drawn
to his rapist to his Shrek Oh gross
let's watch it happen hey that's really
the exact description of the [__]
play
I never my real parents I was told by my
caretakers that before I was born
my father passed away after a lengthy
battle with lung cancer it was only a
week before the day of my birth my
mother an extremely difficult delivery
and she died the day after my birth even
though I never knew my parents I missed
them with all my heart I never got to
know their voices family buys very touch
or their love I grew up in the
supervision of a foster home with many
of their children my age sometimes they
would pick on me and hurt my feelings
the caretakers would not offer my
support as they seemed not understand
the only comfort I found in my empty
life was Shrek his fellows brought joy
to my day and his merchandise brought
material value
the day of my 12th birthday they woke up
slipped on my Shrek 2 t-shirt and walked
downstairs the other children gathered
up to walk me as usual they pointed
fingers hugging me for the fact that I
had no friends outside of the orphanage
to come to my birthday party you don't
have any friends began one of my police
by the Shrek of course the children
laughed even idiots like you should know
that shrek is drek I didn't eat cake
play games or wife of my pals I simply
went upstairs to my room and wrote in my
diary may 18th I wrote in the corner of
the page I've been surrounded by people
all day but I've never felt alone I put
the bed down and closed the book I took
a deep breath and was surprised to find
I heard a soft fatherly voice said the
voice not now and not ever I turned my
head and spotted on the main green
figure Fred I whispered stay why it is
I'm here for your birthday lady my heart
rules a smile crossed my face really
Thank You Fred this is fab DST is my
life up again as flies elated go with me
your prison is now the stairs you said I
hopped up took sex hand and rushed down
the stairs the children all looked at
shrink and die as we had to do what
could the present be I wondered that was
so excited Shrek we didn't meet before
now and put a held his home society like
an airplane he began a cold spread
towards the group of children and the
world his arms the clothesline every
single one of them I could hear the
snapping of necks I was satisfied pieces
of the hair being knocked out the
fullness of the children jerk smiled and
picked up the surviving children by
their hair until he heard them all in
his grasp with his free hand he
unbuttoned his pants and but his thick
pungent [__] spring into the crisp air
with one overhand slink he impaled all
of the children on his [__] and
effortlessly
he [__] all of their corpses until he
finished with a torrent of steaming of
onion sauce he tossed the children
decide no words were exchanged my body
or anything with desires to read his
mind he looked me in the eye and within
an instant I know what I had to do I
give it to my basic primal urges and
tricks Tilly Shrek dink
grunting and leaning down I exposed my
pale cheeks to be aware that let him
fill me inch by inch I was claimed
my Lipson began to wear AI as pain and
pleasure and wolf consume ISIL truck
filled my battlements with other flash
flood of an auskey fluid stay with me
please
I want you to be my daddy I am your
father
my children
[Music]
the crisp night air I close my eyes as I
think of my last thought before drifting
to sleep shrek is love shrek is life
[Music]
that's truthfully one of the more
disturbing ones in this franchise that
was like not even funny it was such a
yes like this is getting very real like
this seems like truly traumatic stuff
this guy's going through and how he's
psychologically damaged and all these
things like it's their brain into too
much realism and then the Shrek then you
totally forget is a [__] children's
character and you just buy it as this
monster who likes to murder children
lose his penis I think that's one of the
most disturbing of this is that he's
talking as if they're children I mean
they look like they're adults but he's
saying that they're children
yeah yeah I was laughing because it was
just like so disturbingly uncomfortable
like oh my god I can't believe I'm
watching this right now that doesn't
seem like they have a sense of humor
about it I guess that's the point like
that's what made the first one kind of
funny was like they committed to it but
that even seemed to know what it was
aware of that was funny this doesn't
seem like there's a touch of humor to it
I really I really worry because this
anybody can just go on the computer and
look this up and I babysit kids and I
have a lot of kids in my life that I
care about and love and to imagine them
going on in the computer and finding
this [__] like seriously disturbs me I
was doing reactions for you
right I mean I guess it got the job done
Oh
disturbed that was the point there's no
way there could have possibly been any
other purpose of this other people it's
like what they tried to do was get
people emotionally first and then
[__] clamp down with some disgusting
sickening content yeah that's the that's
the thing is like he's I just wish it
was a little funny like if there was it
was funnier in some touch like it
wouldn't have been as disturbing like
yeah I get that other than that that
doesn't seem to be much of a point to
this video other than to just disturb
people so they can get a laugh out of it
we're gonna make a petition to take this
video down like would you want your kid
to watch that movie after they had seen
something like this yeah I wouldn't want
that to happen I wouldn't want them to
ever be reminded of what they saw well I
just want to establish that even bad
guys are also good on the inside so
Shrek looks like this horrible monster
at first you'll see you can look past
[Applause]
anyway guys if you're new to the channel
you can subscribe to the real rejects
where will you keep it or do like select
so can't do this wish likes what Shrek
boom kick veronica has a channel to
where she does vlogs and a lot of covers
these days soon hopefully soon she'll
put up her original music koopa troopa
poopa ryan give me a shout out please
koopa troopa PUFA you a scoop Anupa
those aren't words that I said I've
heard your name for I've heard his name
before maybe to Koopa Troopa poopa I
thought Koopa Troopa food was what we
called you know the thing that we do
something
oh nothing would I take it on me when
you want it I'm kidding I do not take a
[__] on my girlfriend but that is what
the Koopa Troopa poop is re tick-tock oh
hey love you man
bro give me a shadow awesome review by
the way are tick tock oh dude that is a
cool name I imagine it's like underwater
talk no that could be the name of like a
band I feel like there's a big mean to
it either he was just like oh they don't
fit or there's like a legit meaning to
art dick talking I think there's two
random words put together it made it
often I don't know Veronica I you know I
don't know like artsy talker like
imagine a taco for a second there's
there's lettuce beef or chicken cheese
sometimes tomatoes underwater would it
be like water proof taco would stay
crunchy like what happened he drowns
Mexicans the taco represents the Mexican
the name of his ship is called Arctic
taco like he goes on a ship with them
and then he drowns them in the sea yeah
that's the camer ask for shadow ages ago
you said I was on your special shadow
this was so far I haven't got a
shout-out so you can give me one next
video she has the gamer if I told you
that and I'm into it it's because I
didn't remember Jen yeah jazz jazz yo
but that's your real name
hmm probably not actually jazz isn't
some guy who spends his day on YouTube
has the name of like it's very tense
Caucasian boy that searches in the ocean
he was kind of a dick too he's the Alpha
yeah and he gets that blonde girlfriend
who's kind of a [__] it'll cheat on him
one day yeah things like red she's gonna
play video games he doesn't stay on
YouTube he doesn't even know what the
Internet is he has dial-up now he like
rides a skateboard and
Rice's bacon stuff yeah so Chazz the
gamer what's your real [__] name I
don't know you do I want to know you a
little bit and if we like you will
consider will consider welcoming you
into our life for a night you know
candles I don't think I don't think he'd
be able to handle that some jazz music
you wouldn't be able to handle it
jazz music jazz with the jazz cheesy
she had the up in here
[Laughter]
[Music]